pensemos en europa como si fuera una
comunidad de vecinos tenemos un
presidente que se encarga de poner orden
los vecinos que se olvidan de pagar la
comunidad y hasta el vecino que amenaza
con mudarse si los demás no dejan de
hacer ruido váyase señor cuesta vaya sí
pero en general el buen ambiente y las
ideas comunes son lo que mantienen la
comunidad a flote tanto es así que
algunos vecinos se han formado sus
propias organizaciones dentro de la
comunidad para asegurarse de que todo
funciona a la perfección como sería en
la unión europea o la ostra por ejemplo
pero hay un vecino que vive ahí y que
hace poco ruido tampoco que se ha
quedado fuera de todos esos grupos y que
además no comparte las aficiones de los
demás de respetar los derechos humanos
de sus ciudadanos o de darles una
democracia transparente este país es
bielorrusia y de ella vamos a hablar hoy
resulta increíble pensar que en pleno
siglo 21 en europa uno de los derechos
humanos y del buenrollismo internacional
una dictadura haya conseguido mantenerse
al margen de la fiesta de democracia que
comenzó tras la caída del muro de berlín
pero en bielorrusia y a pesar de la
celebración periódica de elecciones
alexander lukashenko lleva gobernando lo
mismo que yo llevo viva en esta tierra
en julio de 1994 y en las que
probablemente fueron las últimas
elecciones libres de bielorrusia hasta
la fecha lukashenko fue elegido
presidente con un apabullante 80% de la
población sin sorpresas en bielorrusia
la oposición no ha obtenido ni un solo
escaño en las elecciones legislativas de
ayer una vez elegido lukashenko modificó
la constitución por un referéndum
celebrado dos años después que
incrementaba su poder como presidente en
2004 y tras haber ganado otras
elecciones en 2001 y también mediante un
referéndum suprimió la limitación
constitucional de un máximo de dos
mandatos presidenciales consecutivos lo
que le daba vía libre para justificar su
presencia en el gobierno hasta el
infinito
y dos años y tres procesos electorales
después lukashenko sigue a la cabeza de
bielorrusia y lo que es más interesante
su popularidad no parece disminuir a
pesar de la crisis económica que
atraviesa uno de los países más pobres
de europa una crisis tan grande que para
que os hagáis una idea y el oro si ha
tenido que redenominar el rublo
bielorruso el pasado julio
quitándole hasta cuatro ceros a la
derecha
entonces qué es lo que hace que un líder
tan poco carismático consiga perdurar
tantísimo en el tiempo
estabilidad bienes ha habido que
lukashenko viene de una familia modesta
y que antes de ser presidente de
bielorrusia fue vicepresidente de una
granja colectiva estatal es este pasado
humilde lo que hace que los vio los
rusos se sientan identificados con él y
confíen en que sabrá defender sus
intereses además la permanencia durante
dos décadas de la misma persona al mando
de bielorrusia ha generado entre los
ciudadanos una idea de estabilidad que
un gobierno democrático no podría darles
especialmente en el contexto que está
atravesando ahora mismo su vecina
ucrania eso y que desde hace unos años
la tasa de desempleo se encuentra en
torno a un 1% por el control casi total
del gobierno sobre la economía por eso a
pesar de la recesión que atraviesa el
país
lukashenko es y seguirá siendo la mejor
opción a ojos de los bielorruso aunque
desde el punto de vista occidental sea
de todo menos un líder deseable
mano de hierro
también sabemos que lukashenko no se
anda con chiquitas y que igual que
cualquier otro dictador basa su
permanencia en el poder muchas veces en
el uso de la fuerza por las elecciones
presidenciales en bielorrusia se
saldaron con manifestaciones de la
oposición y las detenciones de cientos
de personas incluidos varios candidatos
a la presidencia en el caso de
bielorrusia esto viene reforzado por uno
la permanencia de la caja de que ahora
mismo se disfraza del comité para la
seguridad estatal de bielorrusia con
y 2 el hecho de que la pena de muerte
aún sea legal en el país las confesiones
de los jóvenes se habrían obtenido a la
fuerza aún así ambos son condenados a
morir de un tiro en la nuca
bielorrusia es el único país de europeo
que mantiene vigente la pena de muerte
en su ordenamiento jurídico las
autoridades bielorrusas justifican su
mantenimiento en el gran apoyo que goza
entre la población el 80 por ciento de
los vuelos rusos se postulan a favor de
la medida pero a parte del apoyo popular
esta medida es de gran ayuda para el
hermético régimen de lukashenko ya que
gracias a ella poca gente se atreve a
hacerle cara a pat k.o papac como se le
conoce en bielorrusia curiosamente más
que por crímenes contra individuos la
pena capital se suele aplicar por
crímenes contra el estado lo que en una
dictadura se traduce simplemente por
oposición al régimen la unión europea
exige la puesta en libertad de todos los
opositores detenidos y encarcelados
desde diciembre de 2010 cuando la
oposición salió a las calles para
denunciar el fraude en las elecciones
presidenciales no se sabe exactamente a
cuánta gente ha castigado bielorrusia de
esta manera pero sí se sabe que en 2016
ha tenido lugar la primera ejecución
después de tres años de una pausa que
comenzó por las sanciones impuestas por
la unión europea tras la ex
y desaparición de dos miembros de la
oposición las sanciones que prohibían a
lukashenko ya otras 170 personas viajar
a europa además de sanciones económicas
han sido retiradas por la supuesta
mejora de la situación de los derechos
humanos en el país algo ilógico pero que
podría explicarse con el siguiente punto
de la estrategia política de lukashenko
balanceo de este a oeste lukashenko sabe
perfectamente que la economía que dirige
no tiene nada que hacer sin sus vecinos
bielorrusia es un país sin salida al mar
que depende totalmente del comercio o
bien con rusia o con la unión europea
así que si tiene que dejar de lado
temporalmente a putin por pactar con
europa o viceversa no tiene
inconveniente en hacerlo la última
prueba de ello la entrada en el
parlamento en 2016 de las primeras
opositoras desde la llegada de
lukashenko para tratar de acercarse a
occidente tras 20 años de ausencia la
oposición bielorrusa ha logrado un
escaño en el parlamento otra jugada
magistral del país fue alzarse como
mediador entre ambas partes durante el
conflicto de ucrania en 2014 y 2015 con
los acuerdos de mills que deberían haber
puesto fin al conflicto lo que le valió
el beneplácito de la unión europea
aunque ojo que hay que recordar que
bielorrusia es un país miembro tanto de
la comunidad de estados independientes
como de la organización del tratado para
la seguridad colectiva que viene a ser
el nuevo pacto de varsovia estado por
rusia por lo que por mucho que se
acerque a europa bielorrusia siempre le
deberá una cierta lealtad a rusia aunque
cabe destacar que los primeros que
adoran a rusia son los propios
ciudadanos
cuando se les pregunta con quién se
siente más relacionado
a europa tres cuartas partes de los
vuelos rusos responden rusia algo que no
pasa por ejemplo en las zonas libres de
ucrania o en los bálticos cabe destacar
que al igual que sus vecinos del norte y
tras la guerra de ucrania los bielorruso
se están preguntando ahora si ellos
serán los siguientes en ser visitados
por las fuerzas armadas rusas a priori
no parece que vaya a ser el caso ya que
los gobiernos de ambas partes tienen una
muy buena relación y bielorrusia ya
aloja algunas bases militares rusas a
las que el kremlin puede acceder sin
necesidad de usar la fuerza pero no os
asustéis que a pesar de todo bielorrusia
es un país totalmente visitable y os
puedo asegurar que mins es una ciudad
preciosa y totalmente segura
así que os atrevéis y os sacáis la vista
podéis visitarla y dejarnos vuestras
experiencias en los comentarios
un saludo y hasta la próxima
a mí
y suscribiros al canal que mola mucho